every mile of this trip was to get me
faster than Jackson storm
faster the cars franchise is chocked
full of undeniable Talent ranging from
famous actors comedians writers and
surprisingly even people who have never
stepped foot onto an animated film in
their life get ready to be surprised by
some of the names that come up in this
list let's get into it holy lightning
you ready oh yeah Lightning's ready
number one the car's hero himself
Lightning McQueen a lefty righty backy
backy Junior okay does this make you mad
yes it does after many on-screen roles
dating as early as 1997 Owen Wilson's
very first role in animation was in 2006
with the first Cars movie he continues
on with the franchise and truly what
would cars be without Lightning McQueen
are you kidding of course I want to keep
racing after his introduction to the
cars world he continued to pick up other
animated roles in movies like The
Fantastic Mr Fox Marmaduke and Freebird
number two naturally cast as the
hilarious pickup truck and Lightning
McQueen's best friend Mater I know you
wouldn't leave without saying to that
this was actually Larry's first big
screen role so of course he returned for
Cars 2 Cars 3 and various spin-offs like
Mater's Tall Tales and cars on the road
his favorite scene of all time is in
Cars 3 when Mater and Lightning go
tractor-tipping we treat the tractors
like cows oh my gosh first time I ever
saw that I was howling number three
Lightning McQueen's bubbly sidekick in
Cars 3 Cruz Ramirez cristella Alonso is
an actor writer producer and comedian
who pops up off the screen with her role
as Lightning's trainer we've been
driving on tires a long time have you
ever stopped to get to know them to come
up with the backstory for Cruz the
creators actually utilized cristella's
own personal backstory it's silly to
just not grab onto it and just try and
put that into the character the big
issue that Cruz has in the movie is her
confidence and her ability to be a
successful Racer the only thing I ever
really wanted was to be a racer
cristella went through the same thing
with stand-up comedy everyone around me
would say oh that's such a silly dream
for a while I kind of listened to them
number four Leah delaria voices the
rugged School Bus by the name name of
Miss fritter
boys we got us a couple of rookies she's
a well-known actor comedian and Jazz
Singer she even performs the song
freeway of love for the Cars 3
soundtrack working on a Pixar film was a
big bucket list item for her she's a
long time fan so to you know get that
phone call please I was dancing around
in my manager's office so excited she
was also given a lot of freedom to
ad-lib some of her lines then they go
give it something else and you give it
something else and they throw lines at
you and you do those lines number five
this one might be a bit of a shock it's
a pleasure to be here chick and actually
I prefer the term statistical analyst
Carrie Washington gets so much praise
for her dramatic roles on shows like
Scandal and films like Rey and Django
Unchained so to see her as the voice of
Natalie certain in Cars 3 seems a bit
out of the ordinary but actually it's
not so much I'm such a huge fan of the
cars franchise and quite honestly a fan
of everything that Disney Pixar does
she's also so relieved to be able to be
in something her kids can watch number
six this franchise doesn't shy away from
these on the nose cameos the voice of
Junior Midnight Moon is voiced by Junior
Johnson he's legendary in the world of
American Racing he won 50 NASCAR races
in his career before returning in 1966.
they are here to steal RC looking for
your loss Mojo it makes sense they would
base a character who also happens to be
one of the late Doc Hudson boys after
him even his character's car model is
based on Junior Johnson's old 39 Ford
number 7. this is a neat Cameo for the
cars franchise Lewis Hamilton the
real-life race driver is behind the
voice of Cruz's electronic personal
assistant in cars 3. oh what about
Hamilton Hamilton here who's Hamilton he
also got to step into the Cars 2 movie
as the voice of himself Lewis Hamilton
number eight Luigi the Italian Fiat who
runs the car's tire shop oh it's
beautiful
ugly look if you like it was paved By
Angels though he's not as seasoned of a
voice actor as some of the others on
this list he's very well known for his
on-screen roles from Wings which ran for
over seven years Men In Black and The
Marvelous Mrs maisel number nine Guido
coroni gets to be the voice of the
forklift Guido you might also recognize
his voice as Tony from Monsters Inc
surprise he used to work as a technical
director for many years at Pixar
Animation Studios so voice acting was
all very new to him I guess they liked
the way he said pit stop and then they
decided to keep me for the whole
duration of the project Pizza
number 10 Carr's very own resident judge
and Doctor Doc Hudson Sheriff
why don't you go down get yourself a
quart of oil that flows Paul Newman is
an oscar-winning performer who starred
in Classics like Cat on a Hot Tin Roof
in 1958 The Hustler in 1961 and Cool
Hand Luke in 1967. his appearance in the
animated world was one of the last
things he ever did as he passed away at
age 83 in 2008. number 11 also known as
fabulous flow the hilarious V8 Cafe
owner you've also definitely seen her as
Ruby on the hit show blackish she's a
huge fan of the cars franchise and she
was so excited to share her experience
working on the films she even went into
the V8 Cafe in carsland and immediately
told the kids who worked there that she
was behind the voice of flow
they say ma'am did you want fries with
that yeah they didn't believe her until
they were not having me and then I did
Dance I got lots of gas they would ah I
thought it was really cute number 12.
the souped up Chevy Impala and the love
of flow's Life Ramon he also owns the
local body shop in Radiator Springs hey
can you believe it man he actually
thought doc was a famous race car Cheech
Marin is a seasoned voice actor with
credits and movies like The Lion King
and many many others number 13. the
voice behind Sheriff Carr's resident
police officer typically not an actor
but an author journalist and historian
cars was his first credited acting role
he went on to continue the voice of
sheriff through Cars 2 free and multiple
spin-offs he was also listed as the
Route 66 consultant because of one of
his best-selling books Route 66 the
Mother Road we want to make a movie
about your road and you're the go-to guy
number 14. Sally Carrera everyone's
favorite friendly neighborhood lawyer
that's okay stickers you can take Bessie
Bonnie Hunt is no stranger to voice
acting as she's got an array of credits
dating all the way back to the childhood
classic A Bug's Life catch her voicing
Mrs Flint in the Monsters Inc spin-off
monsters at work you gotta be clean
because even here in hillbilly hell we
have standards number 15. Paul Dooley
voices Sarge the Khaki green 1942 World
War II Willy's army jeep I didn't tread
shoot the freezing mind fighting in the
big one so that you could squatting your
igloo all day and chant he's also been
on the show 16 candles and voiced
animated characters from shows like
Sesame Street Batman and recess the cars
franchise is so full of talent that it
would be near impossible to list every
single one in this video who was your
favorite performer and who else do you
think we should have included in the
list let us know in the comments
[Music]